good morning Kurt well Ross how's your
morning going
my morning is terrific Kurt I'm having
my first cup of coffee and it's bitterly
cold here in Australia where I live uh
probably a bit warmer where you are but
um I'm very very happy because I've just
seen the Douglas Dean Johnson report on
some legislation that I've known is
coming for a while which is the um
gillibrand Amendment which essentially
requires holders of non-earth origin or
exotic UAP materials they give them six
months to make it available to Arrow the
pentagon's UAP investigation office and
whilst it's dry and Dusty legislation
it's extraordinarily significant to see
the Pentagon
putting in black and white text
references to non-human origin
technology
essentially it's an explicit admission
of what people like myself and David
grush the UAP witness have known for
some considerable time that there are
witnesses that have come forward to the
Congress oversight committees notably
the house permanent Select Committee for
intelligence and also the Senate Select
Committee for intelligence and multiple
Witnesses whether the debunkers
denialists want to know it or not have
given evidence about their knowledge of
a legacy crash retrieval and reverse
engineering program
that is in operation right now that your
Country Canada is involved in and I
think slowly but surely we are
incrementally getting closer to an
acknowledgment that there is a truce
behind all of this you said that you and
David Rush know about do you feel as if
you know this
I've been in the um difficult position
even the first time that I spoke to you
of having confidential sources who are
not yet prepared to go public and
um uh in recent times David grush of
course has been one of them
people who support his contention that
there is a crash retrieval program that
has been in existence for some
considerable time
involving the retrieval of non-human
technology and that there has been
secret agreements within the five eyes
Alliance for the retrieval of that
technology and more importantly that the
United States in collaboration with
other countries has been involved in the
attempted reverse engineering of that
technology
and yes I have multiple Witnesses who
purport to be knowledgeable about the
Legacy UAP crash retrieval and reverse
engineering program
including David grush who are at the
right time prepared to come forward with
their evidence
evidence other than testimonial coming
um yeah there probably will be I mean I
think a lot depends frankly on how the
Congress handles it from here
I'll be honest with you my friend I'm
very skeptical quite glum at the moment
but
um the possibilities that the Congress
is going to run with this
uh I do see and hear from Individual
representatives and Senators who are
dedicated
and determined to get to the truth of
this matter
but I think that there are competing
interests here you have to I mean I
don't want to sound like some wacky
conspiracy theorist but the reality is
that the the military and the
intelligence community in the United
States are an extremely formidable and
Powerful Lobby in the Congress
many congressmen and senators are
reliant on support from that industry
for their continued re-election
including people who sit on the
respective committees in the Congress
and really I think at the moment where
we're at at the moment is
you have
since David Rush went public a few weeks
ago
you have people in the skeptic debunker
camp and quite rightly I think saying
well where's the evidence
and debunkers quite rightly say well he
hasn't provided any yet
but I think there's a bit of willful
blindness going on there people are
ignoring the fact that Mr grush legally
faces criminal prosecution if he reveals
the full extent of what he knows and
about which he has testified not only to
the two Congressional intelligence
committees but also to the Inspector
General of defense and the Inspector
General of the intelligence community
and I don't want to sound like a
long-winded lawyer and I really think I
have to keep on saying this until until
the sun goes down but the simple fact is
uh his evidence has been provided under
oath to the relevant government agencies
and committees that are entitled to
Heroes and I respect and understand why
there are officials in our intelligence
and community community and defense
Community who want to keep certain
aspects highly confidential I can
actually understand why they're doing
that knowing what I know not from David
grush but from other sources I can
understand why certain things certain
Technologies certain potential
weaponries certain capabilities are
being kept confidential what I do find
increasingly bewildering
is the reluctance of mainstream media to
acknowledge a growing reality
I've just this morning read a stupid
piece written by a columnist in my
national newspaper in Australia the
Australian newspaper and it's a column
entitled space aliens are everywhere oh
wait
and essentially it's a piss take it's a
um it's an attack on so-called
conspiracists
uh who've um
uh said that the Pentagon knows all
about UFOs but have withheld it from the
president and the Congress preferring to
exploit the non-human technology and
essentially it's a piss take it's a
laugh a whole idea the whole concept
that there might be some veracity to
this
and the thing that really shocks me is I
guess I'm lucky because I've been
talking to people now for several years
who had a knowledge of this program I've
been no doubt it exists and people can
call me a tin foil head crazy as much as
they like
but the simple fact is it's real
and it's slowly but surely dribbling out
I've spoken to senators and
representatives in the Congress and
staffers who've told me that they have
been in the room when credible Witnesses
have given evidence multiple Witnesses
have given evidence about retrieved
non-human technology
so my friend the only question in my
mind and I'm very very skeptical in
light of the ridiculous blowback from
even people in the UFO UAP Community who
should know better skills for the
Pentagon people who are conspiring in
the cover-up
there is a real problem at the moment in
getting mainstream media engagement on
this issue and it's not that there's
some dark conspiracy there's not some
intelligent service Black Men in Black
telling editors not to run the story
what this is is a residual stigma a
taboo that's been attached to this
subject so well and the hilarious thing
is I'm actually talking to people in the
military who want this story out from
within the high levels at the Pentagon
who are frustrated that the national
mainstream media is not engaging with
this issue they are incredulous that the
disinformation campaign has been so
effective that you've now got newspapers
like the New York Times And The
Washington Post either dismissing or
passing or taking their time dragging
their feet on deciding whether or not
they want to investigate the allegations
of a man like David grush
frankly mate I don't know what's going
on in the National newspapers in the U.S
Canada or in Australia and the UK and
most of the world's major newspapers
anymore when an intelligence Insider of
the caliber of David grush comes forward
somebody who has indubitable
credible credentials
who the Pentagon in the three or four
weeks since
he went public
has not laid a glove on his credibility
don't you think don't you think if there
was anything that they could pull out of
the cupboard to attack David grushwood
the Pentagon would have done by now they
are desperately trying to plug the leaks
and stop this from coming out
they're terrified that they are involved
and indeed according to Mr grush
involved in a potentially criminal
conspiracy
there are people at the highest levels
of the Pentagon who have knowingly
covered up and concealed from the
Congress knowledge of a non-human
intelligence and they've done this for
80 plus years
and the thing that is fascinating to me
is we now have legislation that my
colleague and friend Douglas Dean
Johnson has written about today
which specifically states that there's
now a bill written by Senator Kirsten
gillibrand which gives holders of
non-earth origin or exotic UAP material
essentially an amnesty to come forward
with what they know
why would Congress
demand the necessity for such
legislation if they didn't know
something
and what is going wrong with the
Curiosity of the world's greatest
newspapers
this is not as some charge a tinfoil hat
conspiracy theory don't buy into the
line that this is some
spurious allegation made by some wacky
ill-informed intelligence operative this
is somebody David grush is somebody who
at the very highest levels of the U.S
intelligence Community was cleared to
Top Secret
compartmented intelligence more than 2
000 special access programs
this is a guy with one of the highest
clearances in the U.S intelligence
Community who was tasked by a
congressional mandate to go out as part
of the UAP task force to investigate the
phenomenon to find out the truth of what
America really knows
and you know what he found he found a
hidden crash retrieval Legacy UFO
reverse engineering program that's been
going on since the 1940s and 50s
and frankly I'm at the stage at the
moment where if America's mainstream
media and political leadership doesn't
want to engage with this issue
then let them deny it
and then if the American public don't
care about it
let them get on with their their lives
because
inherently at the heart of all of this
and I know you have a lot of scientists
in your community of watches Kurt
I'm talking to people inside the Legacy
program who tell me frustratedly with
great emotion how much as scientists
they care about the fact that this
knowledge is being kept from a huge
chunk of the human race
but only a select Cadre of people inside
the intelligence military establishment
are privy to this information you just
watched a clip from the theories of
everything channel for the full video
and all its magnificence then click here
and if you'd like to see more then
subscribe enjoy